en faisant ça on a plus l'impression
qu'on est rentré on est on est dans le
même monde que les valides en fait des
trottinettes électriques pour fauteuil
roulant c'est la solution de déplacement
proposé par la société omis plus de 500
personnes à mobilité réduite ont d'ores
et déjà adopté valider le concept régis
harel ont fait partie pour se déplacer
d'un point à un point b par exemple sont
à 3 4 kilomètres à faire dans en temps
normal on aurait pris mon fauteuil je
ralentis à la voiture j'aurais fait un
transfert là on prend la trottinette
plaque on monte dessus ont la tâche on
est parti et c'est efficace hein la
seule difficulté c'est de faire en fait
du du deux roues de passer par le sida
d'un la roue arrière de la trottinette
après je vais poser là sur le système et
je vais juste reculé comme ça et ça y
est ça s'enclenche automatiquement
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai eu à faire
à saint quentin en yvelines et grâce aux
subventions de l'agglomération louer une
trottinette revient entre 45 et 75 euros
par mois le plus si la solution est
approuvée au bout de deux ans la
trottinette et céder aux locataires pour
un euro symbolique où à chaque fois
qu'on fait quelque chose en gros il faut
un truc spécifique qui va coûter très
cher et tout parce que là c'est quelque
chose qui coûte pas très cher primé au
concours d'invention lépine 2020 les
deux modèles proposés permettent
l'optimisation des trajets de distance
moyenne en autonomie avec la seule que
j'ai pris on peut compter une trentaine
de kilomètres donc ça fait pas mal
davantage avec cette trottinette aussi
c'est que pour monter les côtes on monte
plus facilement les côtes avec une roue
électrique devant parce que la
propulsion se fait par l'arrière langer
ça a été pour voir s'adapter justement à
petit c'est aux métriques fauteuil et
tout en ayant quelque chose qui soit
super rapides à mettre au quotidien
quand on veut faire de la trottinette
après deux ans de recherche et
développement la société ovni a lancé le
produit l'année dernière il suffit de
quelques tutos explicatifs pour pouvoir
commencer l'utilisation sur le fauteuil
la trottinette elle peut aussi être
utilisée par des valides tiens on me dit
dans quel rapprocher des roues qui en
fait ce n'est le risque de crevaison et
des francs pour renforcer la sécurité et
de freinage en cas de question il suffit
de contacter la société via son site
internet à terme honni aimerez
démocratiser ce mode sport et effacer la
frontière entre personnes à mobilité
réduite est valide